why is it why is that that salty dogs
like us with a little gray in our hair
and beards
can come to that conclusion and maybe
the new founders the neophytes maybe
don't
i think it's because you know at the
early stages of a company
the founder their personality and their
their
vision and worth of themselves is so
tied up into that exact company concept
they see themselves as one thing
i am this startup and i need to be you
know bull
you know a bull just driving to the
success of the singular startup because
that's what i said i'm going to do
and you know sometimes the paradigm i
would use or the metaphor i use is
saying sometimes you're using a butter
knife trying to cut through marble
you can you can be grinding at that
thing all day for years on years but
you're never going to cut through marble
with a butter knife right
so my perspective is they need to
separate and believe that like look
there's them as a founder
and then there's the startup they're
currently working on right and if that
startup doesn't work out they as a
founder hopefully got smarter and they
take the lessons from that startup
that failed and the time that they've
invested and they realized that actually
was a level up for them
so although the startup didn't work out
they became stronger right
and then they take that strength and
they go to that next startup and go to
the next startup
right and we've i mean just like you've
seen like i've seen companies work for
five years
and really never find growth and i've
seen companies work for five weeks and
see immense growth
right yeah and uh you know and sometimes
it it could be the same type of founder
it's just that they're attacking
different problems that the market
either is or isn't ready for
right but there is that thesis that's
somewhat i think
built into this america dream where it's
almost like well just try harder just
grind harder grind harder grind harder
and the reality is that is true when
it's talking about you as a founder go
grind harder right
but that business you're grinding
against might be just a butter knife
into marble
and yeah there's no amount of grinding
that's gonna solve that problem and the
founder
because they are the founder and from
their position
their point of view is i gotta get
through the marble
and i got a knife in my hand so let's
keep going yeah and they don't see
themselves in this
whereas we as maybe the old salty dogs
who've been through this before
we see it and we look and go oh there
there is an impossible task cutting the
marble but
look at how diligently and how much
how strong that founder has gotten
trying to do something impossible
it's literally like watching in martial
arts somebody just
punched the bag over and over again and
it's like bag's not going anywhere
yep that's exactly right but you're
getting stronger right
that's right and i mean and obviously
you know this as well
when we all select these individuals and
they pitch us and
and we invest into them um at the end
they were investing into
them as a founder right and we think
it's them plus that business but there's
always a possibility it's them plus a
different business right
yes the other thing i found is that the
moment founders take money
they're go if they feel like it's not
working out their goal seems to be
i will still cut this marble until i'm
literally on my last dime to show
conviction
to my investors that i executed the
strategy i sold them
right and yet i often encourage them
like look if you're clear that the
strategy isn't working
and you know at the early stages tell
your investors and
and suggest an alternative suggest your
pivot or return the capital but don't
feel like you have this obligation to
bleed this thing dry
when you're clear the strategy isn't
going to work right which you did at
myspace
well yeah i mean at myspace we we yeah
exactly right we butter knifed that
marble
you know through three different phases
and then clearly
you know went to basically news corp and
said you know no amount of money solves
this problem
you know it's a fundamental problem we
need to walk away from this problem
wow what was that like for you
emotionally after
you know that sunken amount of time you
put into it well it's
i mean it's you know it's disappointing
right for sure right like
um and i wasn't just disappointed for
myself but i would say that
you know it's one of those things that
you certainly know great people around
you when you're in a wartime setting
and you know when myspace entered the
first phase which was like
mass layoffs and mass reconstruction of
the business the second phase which was
a highly publicized
launch and combat you know combat with
facebook and the third phase the kind of
realization of where we are
you know you had some incredible people
um that dedicated their lives to that
mission
um and it's disappointing that we didn't
succeed in that mission right but
um you know i think i felt that
disappointment of the entire team like
look it's not going to work
but there was a sobering moment being
like look there's a lot of good reasons
why this isn't going to work and no
matter how much time and capital we put
in this i don't see a recovery coming
so then let's just move into this model
of like let's extract value how do we
extract value
preserve as much as we possibly can and
let everybody walk away with some level
of pride at the end of this journey